in 2016 i got asked to sing the national
anthem for hillary clinton when she won
enough delegates to become the
democratic nominee for president of the
united states
i only got asked with a couple days
notice and my busy schedule meant that i
couldn't make it to soundcheck
when i got called on stage and started
singing the room of 3 000 people started
singing along with me
and i don't know if you've ever been in
this position before but it felt a
little unpatriotic to ask a room full of
people singing the national anthem to
stop
so instead of seeing the version that i
had strenuously rehearsed for 48 hours i
sang theirs
and i didn't sound my best and i was the
only one that was miked
when i got off stage my phone had blown
up with social media notifications
telling me how terrible i sounded
that i'd ruined my biggest opportunity
that i should never sing again
even snoop dogg made fun of me needless
to say i was absolutely crushed
but it ended up being the best thing
that's ever happened to me it forced me
to go back out there
and go after my dreams despite what the
internet trolls told me
it pushed me to be my best self
this song is a result of that experience
i hope it inspires you to try
[Music]
i know it's a fight
to try and listen
cause i might not
[Music]
selflessly unlearning
is
[Music]
try
but at least i'm living
[Music]
unprepared
to walk away
i won't let the same thing
stop us every time
why isn't that changing
feels like a good bite
take a leap of faith
we should fly
[Music]
is
it's time to see
you